I've opened dev tools and I'll start my
investigation by taking a look at their
actual sizes looks like the first image
is a thousand by 667 pixels and the
second image is also 1000 by 667 pixels
so at least they're resolutions are the
same in the network tab it becomes
pretty clear that they have different
compression levels because the first
image has a size of about 60 kilobytes
while the second is only around 40
kilobytes in both images pretty much
look the same so that's a lot of wasted
bytes saving with quality set to high
can be even more of a problem on mobile
where bandwidth is scarce and the
screens are small later in the course
you'll learn how to serve different
images for displays of different sizes
and different resolutions